[Musica]
duro e non saper parlare e avere tante
cose da dire desideri aspirazioni
sofferenze gioie recriminazioni tutto
diventa fumoso irraggiungibile perché
fagocitato da un silenzio forzato la mia
vita a più di una nascita nato
biologicamente a russia nel 1995
conosciuto il buio dell'abbandono sono
rinato per amore dei me i veri e unici
genitori era loro la luce seppur lontana
dell'amore a cui mi sono aggrappato
separazione e denutrizione erano stati
tanti e tali da compromettere uno
sviluppo omogeneo e causare grosse
disfunzionalità la rabbia del silenzio
forzato salire n furiosa tutte le volte
che cercavo di farmi capire non ci
riuscivo
tutto ciò che era tiro diventava
strumento per manifestare la mia
tremenda furia povero né ma poveri anche
i miei genitori
tutti mi credevano scemo oltre che pazzo
perché ciò che facevo parlava di me più
forte del mio silenzio e ciò era ogni
volta una grande ferita poi a 8 anni
la fortuna si è ricordata di me e ciò
che fino ad allora poteva solo essere
sognato si è realizzato
ho conosciuto brunetta e la
comunicazione facilitata la parola
scritta ha rotto il silenzio finalmente
aveva una voce al meno leggibile e
potevo dimostrare di essere intelligente
dall'inizio scrivere mi ha permesso di
farmi capire un pochino di più ma la
strada è ancora lunga e l'immagine che
io e gli altri avevamo di me era
perdente sarebbero dovuti passare ancora
tanti anni di duro lavoro prima di poter
aspirare ad un discreto controllo
emotivo ed uno più efficace utilizzo e
la tecnica c f a ognuno di noi ha un
obiettivo principe al quale aspirare e
questo passa attraverso tanti sotto
obiettivi adeguati all'età e al livello
di sviluppo raggiunto in quel momento e
credetemi è duro cadere mille volte e
trovare la forza di ricominciare
continuando a crederlo possibile mi
ripeto permettetemelo i veri eroi della
mia storia sono i miei genitori che
hanno continuato a credere in me
contro ogni ragionevolezza così prima ho
dovuto imparare ad incanalare il
desiderio di manifestarvi attraverso
nuove modalità
successivamente ad imparare a farlo con
competenza e infine diventare una
persona socialmente riconosciuta è in
grado di gestirmi in relazioni umane
significative il valore della tecnologia
nel percorso di conquista della mia vera
umanità
se ottima idea il messaggio che vorrei
passare a cambiare lo sguardo verso
l'altro andare oltre
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no